I haven't been laid in a while no that's
I know that's a lot to tell an audience
that doesn't know me but you know if I
don't tell you how am I gonna get laid
all right you got to put it out there in
the universe so it comes back and it's
not that I can't is just I'm doing
something different than I've ever done
before I am getting to know men before I
sleep with them don't do that because oh
my can they talk you out of it no it's
amazing when you just listen for a
second
you'll be like no you cannot have this
like I had this one guy tell me he was
gonna take the bus to my house the bus I
was like this ain't no bus and you gotta
take the bus to it he even said he was
gonna transfer to another bus thank you
guys for laughing at ya know cuz I did
this in Wisconsin apparently they all
ride the bus there it was quiet they
were offended I had one lady she's like
oh she's fancy fancy lady doesn't ride
the bus I don't so this is what I talk
about you know my relationship cuz my
friends won't listen anymore
but I have you like politics I'm not
good at on stage and I wish I was I just
I'm not good at it you know and I have
guilt about not talking about politics I
have what's called black guilt
I know some of you don't know what to do
with that but it's happening you know
times are changing it's when you're
black and you haven't done enough you
feel it you know like I need to do some
marching I need to get a good marching
it's just my allergies are really acting
up I'm more of a seasonal protester
thank you I could do more like the
women's March I wanted to do the first
one in DC I wanted to do that but I have
a weak bladder and I knew the lines for
that bathroom we're gonna be long and
they were they said they were
historically long lines when looking
back in history a picture of me just
waiting in line for the bathroom that's
not what I want
we're straddling a bush because I
couldn't make it just looking at my
girlfriend like I drink a lot of water
I'm just saying I could do more and I
realized that I you know I don't do
enough and I think it's age too I'm
older than I look you know I'm black so
you'll never know but it's happening
it's setting in will you say the wrong
things you don't know stuff I'm not as
woke as I should be and it's
embarrassing
like I've been messing up on my pronouns
lately cuz I met someone who was not a
guy or a girl they were they which is
how they wanted to be referred to and
that's important like I care about that
it's just it's new to me and in a
sentence structurally it makes me sound
like a runaway [ __ ]
like where they are these come lay down
by the river they gonna be mad at that
Joe thank you
[Applause]
you